- So while Drew is chowing down
on her beautiful pork carnitas,
- Mm, they're so good.
- what we're gonna do over here
is actually do a coconut
tres leches bread pudding
which I thought would be
a really nice compliment
to your pork carnitas.
So the first thing we're gonna do actually
is you can take some challah
bread and everyone says
wait for it to go stale.
I'm like, holla!
- Holla!
- I don't have time to
wait for it to go stale.
I just like to toast it lightly,
and that actually will really improve
the texture of your bread pudding.
It's gonna make it absorb much better.
And what-
- So you wanna toast it
just a little bit.
- Just lightly.
Just very lightly.
- Do you do it in the oven?
- You can absolutely do it in the oven,
in the toaster oven, however
you like to toast your bread,
and with that, I mix some coconut flakes.
So, Drew, I sprayed down the base
of this wonderful slow cooker of ours
with some nonstick cooking spray.
I'm gonna toss the bread,
- Could you use
like a coconut oil?
- You could use a coconut oil
which would be really nice actually,
because we're using,
- Because there's already
a little coconut in there.
- There's coconut in there.
And one of our tres
leches is a coconut milk.
So it's coconut milk.
- Mm-hmm, oh!
- I love coconut milk!
- Condensed milk and regular milk,
and then, ooh, I'm making a mess,
and then we have egg yolks,
like seven egg yolks basically,
and two eggs.
So you're gonna whisk
that until all the eggs
are basically broken up and homogeneous,
and then we have a little bit of cinnamon,
actually a lot of cinnamon,
which is really nice,
and some vanilla, and then
half a teaspoon of salt.
Are you impressed?
- I am loving this.
Also, I just think vanilla cinnamon
is one of my favorite-
- But paired with the coconut,
It's just this incredible flavor.
It's really, really lovely.
I think it's magic.
- There's also a little bit
of like a unique French toast element
happening here.
- There absolutely
is a French toast element.
So we're gonna pour that, hopefully,
fully beaten custard in.
- I know.
- I mean,
it smells amazing, guys.
- [Drew] I'm totally hypnotized.
- And then what you're gonna do actually
is just with your spatula,
just press down a little
so the bread starts to soak,
and you're gonna let it sit
for about 10 to 15 minutes
before you turn it on.
- Really?
- And all that does is basically,
let the custard be
absorbed into the bread,
so that when you cook it,
it starts to give you all
these different textures.
You can have a little crunchy,
a little soft, a little moist,
and then you just kick it on to low,
and that takes two and a half
to three hours and it's done.
I'm gonna cut myself a slice.
Let me put that over there.
And the last thing we're gonna do, Drew,
is that we actually made a dulce de leche,
go give it a lick.
It's really good.
- Thank you.
- We made the dulce de leche
- You know where
my mind is, I'm like.
Oh, my god.
- We made it
in the slow cooker as well.
Yep.
- Oh god.
- So that's the leave overnight.
- Oh my god.
- Pop the can in.
Don't do anything to it,
and I'm gonna garnish.
- Wait a minute.
How do you make this?
'Cause this is incredible.
- You put the whole can of condensed milk
into the slow cooker,
fill it with water that goes
two inches above the can,
and set it to low for eight hours.
It is amazing.
- Guys,
this tastes like chocolate caramel.
Mm.
- Shall we give it a taste?
(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh. Okay, I'm going in.
Oh my gosh.
It does have texture.
- Mm-hmm.
It has a lot of texture.
- It's soft and moist,
but it's got crunch,
and toasted-ness.
- Oh, my god.
And it's great for a crowd.
It keeps for a few days you
can even freeze it and reheat.
It's really, really wonderful.
Pilar.
- Mm-hmm.
(audience applauding)
- You guys, this is, I'm just going,
I just went and literally went like this.
- Yes.
- I mean,
this is one of the most
- Maybe that's how
you should serve it.
Like with the can out,
and people just-
- I do like this presentation.
You guys have got to make this.
This is incredible.
It is like caramel and chocolate
had a love child and it's right here.
This is so good.
- So good.
- Thank you for always
expanding our horizons.
(audience cheering)
And just like this meal, Pilar,
I think they make a great combo,
just like us.
(bright music)